- Olinka, the co-founder, and myself
were together for five years.
And we decided to break up.
There was one thing that was kind of
a reminder of our relationship.
Just the mention of, "Who's
gonna take the bunny?"
it felt really hard.
We thought, wouldn't it be
great if there was a place
where you could just store it
and it just stays there and it's safe,
you know it's safe?
But it's just not there
to remind you every day.
To put it simply, Museum
of Broken Relationships
is a collection of items and stories
that were donated by people
after their relationships fell apart.
"I would like to donate
the target that my ex shot
with an AK-47 when we were together
at the shooting range in L.A."
What else do you do when you
come from Denmark to L.A.?
You know, you go to the shooting range.
We get objects from all over the world
and we open packages, and,
like, "What's inside?"
And oftentimes, it's a
really good surprise.
"In the Zagreb Hospital,
I met a beautiful,
young, and ambitious social worker
from the Ministry of Defense.
Love was born when she helped
me get certain materials
which, as a war invalid,
I needed for my below-knee
prothesis. The prothesis
endured longer than our love.
It was made of sturdier material.
The reason we did this
is because when we had,
when we experienced a
problem of what to do
with this something,
we were sure it already exists,
and we went to Google
it to find the place.
We just found advice
about how to destroy it.
There are really some
that are so striking,
I mean, a parachute from Finland,
it's a pretty powerful one.
"I met him on my first parachute jump.
I was really scared, but this handsome man
who was my tandem jump
instructor, saved me.
We loved to play in the sky,
and we loved each other.
Then he died in a parachute accident."
That's always a thing
with crowdsourced things:
You have no idea what you're gonna get.
"When I moved out across the
country, I took the toaster.
That will show you.
How are you going to toast anything now?"
Love and breakup, it's such
important part of our lives
but you don't know anything about it,
you're just left on your
own to experience it.
And if you have great
parents or great friends
they will help you out. If not, nothing.
It's really like that famous sentence
that everybody's happy in the same way,
and unhappy in their special way.
A mobile phone from Zagreb, Croatia.
"It was 300 days too long.
He gave me his mobile phone so
I couldn't call him anymore."
It's a permanent museum.
One of the most visited in Croatia,
which is for me still funny.
Now we're friends and business partners.
We just changed the relationship from
one to another, and it can be done.
I mean, we're proof that it can be done.
We still travel a lot,
with visiting exhibitions
all over the world.
And it's really great when you see how
well people respond.
I mean, that's why we do it, really.